das aushängeschild der stadt das dann
nicht sagen herr zwei videos ein
wird ein von 20 leben noch durch meine
lieben freunde jetzt willkommen zurück
zu einer weiteren folge hetero zusammen
mit jo ich bin hier in statt rot
das einfach drei herzen ab die zu
bekommen und letzte folge war richtig
krass war ich bin zudem notiert ich hab
mein weg zurück gefunden und wir haben
ein alien creeper gesehen ja und wir
haben ein ein adapter krebber meister
wir haben ein snapshot post gemacht und
jetzt machen wir noch ein instagram
stellte aber es mache ich erst 13 mäßig
welche neuer startblöcke mir mal dass
wir jetzt hier machen das ja ich dann
bitte ganz versuchen wir machen jetzt
ein instagram instagram bild in eine
youtube aufnahme folge das ist so und
währenddessen schreibst du noch einen
facebook post um alles einfach was es
gibt oder twitter tumblr auch und fleiß
und ihr könnt dann ja nachher wenn denen
die folge anleihen ist könnt ihr erste
durch wundern warum ich das geschäft
gepostet habe und dann können wir als
rentier wegen dir wenn du hast jetzt
zahlt wenn ihr jetzt mal die folge sie
geht noch einmal die beschreibung geht
auf den instagram link da und dann geht
ihr nochmal auf das oft es wurde drauf
und schreibt alle zusammen darunter
aber mit ganz vielen zwei liegt die so
ganz große augen hören
zurich tel den brauche ich dann davon ja
so viel wie du brauchst in russland zum
beispiel so ein oberteil haushalt 813
oder für die kanzlerin hose machen oder
schon ein helm reicht schon damit auch
schon magnetisch angezogen wurde so ein
helms auch schon praktisch alle heißen
magnetisch überhaupt ja das heißt alle
items ungewissen umkreis werden
magnetisch text wieder angezogen und
wenn inventars voll ist dann geht das
halt um dich rum so um dich rum
weißt du was ich meine firma her ach ja
da war so ein weizen bei der unia was
los erst trifft da hab ich gesehen wird
morgen den analysen auf dein leben in
dem die an diesem update diene weder
diese dubstep lieber gesehen hat ist
sein leben irgendwie verändert
nein das fing schon mit pferden an wir
haben alle so unsere er zwar in diese
komme hat susan würmer die pinguine und
bärenwiese den pinguin haben sich auch
schon getötet
das stimmt ja auch dann stellst du ja
immer eine weile turm ist also wie immer
okay da war ich stärker angespannt weil
ich dachte es kommt vielleicht liefert
ja und dann lässt man steht hingehen
oder zeigt mir das erst mal ganz kurz
irrt ich weiß dass genügend zeit für
eine tolle ganz schnell das kostet
zweitmarkt du kannst aber auch mit
minecraft gold bezahlen ein bisschen was
du kannst einfach den sport und ich
gucke nein ich denke ich hätte auf was
ich denke aber mal gespannt was du so
hasst
hier kannst du schild haben das habe ich
selber sogar ein besseres ergebnis
einfach ein besseres da tauschen wer von
den top ten mal was anderes kommt jetzt
was haste gold oder diamanten dafür in
schweden alessandra hat für mich kein
wert mehr kommt jetzt ihr okay danke
thank you so viel romantik mir bitte
warte ich gebe jetzt essen und du willst
mir das essen weil das es da dass
proviant für die fahrt da habe ich mit
für bezahlt gibt mir das geben weil du
bist der führer hier und dann sagst du
du musst jetzt sagen das ist für die
fahrt gibt mir das jetzt das ist dafür
da dafür hast du auch bezeugt wo alles
inszeniert hier bei minecraft ihre hits
hallo frank crafter willkommen in der
stadt das anprobieren für die fahrt muss
danke
er wurde schon als ich das war ein krieg
wieder aufgebaut
hier lagert stieg er starb durch
dummheit hier lagert im erst nicht so
gut mal steht der beste hier starb
dehner unerwartet und heftig ms excel
schon wieder und komme ja und die
anderen sind alle weg eigentlich bin ich
nämlich schon warte wie viel sechsmal
gestorben
im sport bei dir aber ihr habt schon ein
paar schöne strässchen hier die haben ja
noch nicht vor aber ich bin oft für
straßkirchen das aushängeschild der
stadt nicht schlagen einen laden und ein
herz beispiel durch ein
wird ein von 20 leben noch und rechtlich
ins wasser gegangen wäre ja wie
angegriffen
ich will mit einem halben herzen am
brett ins wasser gelaufen aber ja nie
angegriffen gefühlt dass ich mal richtig
krass ist ja ich wollte dass du das ding
rein gehst gibt auch ein guter brauch
mal ablehnen
dass mir hier hochschleppen was das denn
da einlassen backstage entrollt ist da
reingehen
da war war es aussehen gestellt der
stadt und welt das hier
ich weiß gar nicht dass ich hier bin
zugezogener neureicher gar nicht
ausgeleuchtet hier
man gehört nach helfen dass sein board
pattern cool aber school das dach auf
jeden fall
ich hab jetzt von dem das portal werde
ich bestimmt nicht reingehen das ist
bestimmt die nein das ist wirklich nicht
ich gehe auch vor dir
okay ich bin ein bildchen und guck mal
was jetzt darf man sich abbauen
darf man das verstehen können stehe ihr
schreiben ja du kannst die na ja sagen
er darf in seinem porsche diamant
blogger abbauen und die gold blogger
und wenn ich erzähle dass bestimmt ist
das denn hier wenn alle so dass aus
diesem redwood place ist voll cool aus
bei euch ja das ist halt von firma das
haben wir gesagt so unser baustil aber
wir haben uns noch ein bisschen
gestritten fest machen oder nicht
also einfach mal so gar nicht gestritten
aber ich weiß auch nicht aber das ist
auf jeden fall die offizielle vorgabe
als wir ändern das kann alles darauf um
ich auch sie ist ja man merkt aber das
ist schon mal mehrere arbeit habt achso
hälfte schon red wurde ja sieht man ja
ich glaube wenn ich zu dir möchte müssen
wir jetzt einen weil sonst die folge
schon zu wenig wenn ich bei dir sein
willst du dir ich sagte es gibt noch
kurzüberblick aber nur von der stelle
aus okay okay 321 euro zu das ist das
außenamt zudem hatte daumen sie brauchte
merkt den es gibt wohl aber wurde es
umgebaut seiner borkum west noch nichts
wissen muss umziehen ist sich da nicht
vielleicht eine kleine entschädigung wer
weiß es noch nicht
es gab streit deswegen aber das war
eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm aber
alle dachten es wäre schlimm
und naja ich hab mir darum noch
charakters hingebaut eigene kosten zu
machen aber im da es auch ganz gut aus
verteidigungsmechanismus aber es ist
egal weil das abgebaut wird und
stattdessen die brocken kommt jetzt
würde ich gerne auf dem weg gehen zu
deiner stadt sich gern noch angucken in
dieser folge um dort an dienstag als
alfie als andenken zu posten das muss
ich weiß es nicht ich bin ich
hergekommen
daran glaube ich aber dass von
siebeneinhalb mal jemand von hier war
dann dass sie aus wie nick reilly habe
ich irgendwo hoch gegraben ja auch
geschlafen hast du dich ich glaube hier
aus dem ans haus erde lassen nichts
kaputt machen nein ich bin ich aus dem
haus sicher hat mich da irgendwo hoch
gegraben
ich muss irgendwann noch sein so was
muss ich muss gar nicht es ist ein weg
nach hause du kannst ja auch jetzt foren
wenn du jetzt muss der tat fragen hier
dürfen die hübsche leute monate
ach so erhöht dass das soll nichts für
dich das ist natürlich nur für dich ich
dachte das ist hier in dem haus ist aber
ich war ich war ja nur der der punkt ist
ja auch irgendwo oder sogar auf der
anderen seite noch ein bisschen weiter
vielleicht sogar hier noch ein bisschen
weiter
ok ok ok aber aber wir schaffen das
level ist der des tail ist er jedoch
nicht zur folge freuen
mein kopf war sicher das so weit weg
warst du meintest du bist irgendwo und
man hasst ihn hoch gebaut
ich glaube nicht dass es so weit weg ist
das macht keinen sinn doch weiter oben
an seinem linken bin ich glaube das war
ja dass bei simone verein genial einfach
gucken ja sie muss der schon wieder nach
hause
ja wir gucken jetzt einfach mal bist du
vielleicht hier in der seite ist auch
ein dass ein kleines loch ich bin ich
habe mir extra du kannst dich ernsthaft
nicht mehr daran erinnern
ich bin hier unter seinem haus sa bi
sieht sich nach portal aus hier ist
einfach nur dunkel scheiße luca du bist
jetzt hier gefangen
du wirst nie wieder nach hause kommen
dudas wenn ich gar nicht so schlimm
unserer stadt ist vielleicht von hier
kommt von da ich weiß nicht so löcher
hast du dich irgendwo hoch gebaut mit
sand und ich kenne es ja ich hab mich
wählen mit sand irgendwo hoch gebaut
ja vielleicht doch ein einst großen
kummer ich musste ja hier doktor watson
spielen und für dich den detektiv
spielen können hier ist so ein loch ja
hier sogar licht
ich glaube das ist hier ja dass das ja
jetzt ist guck mal wichtig die tiefe
spielen musste für dich nicht allein das
ist okay
oh mein gott oh mein gott ich sehe ganz
zu den namen die mädchen okay
ja war dass unsere truppen haben setzt
rapper wieder hin als wäre das cool so
wenn die treppe dahin den hat würde ich
jetzt von hierdurch soundso hier sehen
wie uschi und ina karabasz hier er dem
tier und enis alushi und peene ach so
dass der pinguin kopf den 1
ach so much penis habe ich den witz
verstanden hier garantiert das sieht
aber ganz nett bei euch aus als das
jetzt so als ob man so eine ganz neue
stadt er kommt ja wo habt ihr da ich
sagt iris geworden ist dass von dem von
war dazu dass du hier höre das von uns
ja ernsthaft werden so hässlich gebaute
alte manuel pape komplex ist gar nicht
gut aus von hinten sie jetzt aus so eine
steinstatue ja soll ich auch das ist nur
so blender mäßig weißt du wer da von
hinten kommt denke nokia startet in
dieser form sind
da kommt natürlich auch weiter rate bei
euch den song kombis ruft da wurde das
hab ich gesehen da friedhof wird gar
nicht auf die taschen draufstehe war
vollauf wurden meine gehabt und neuer
doch von den schönen friedhof als ich
noch besser haben als inspiration
ich muss das jetzt ein bisschen als
inspiration nutzen damit auch irgendwann
mal so schön haben ja es ist schon gut
ihr wisst gar nicht wie gut ist hat den
dienstgrad boxen
ja ich hier ist unsere öffentliche
verzauberung skarke nutzen erlaubt aber
nicht um stehen umstellen komplett mit
weiterhin mit dem einnehmenden ja unser
ich muss auch wieder zurückkommen
hier wohnt kev davon kev befragt
angefangen das durch ganz sie ist ganz
süß aus bei ihm kommen ja weniger bare
jahres meisten café generell wertvoll
ja das ist gut sortiert epic wertvoll
bei ihm ist einfach alles märz geilo
aber wertvoll
hier haben wir gestern ist bei der
bruchbude
du wirst du dann ist jetzt unser
öffentliche klare herzen holec wächst
das nach branche tätig gebrauchten
programms zusieht produktivität auf ganz
kleinem raum eine chaotische bode ja
solar und stellte heraus dass wir gut
schlafen dann ist regen und links mit
erwarte nicht direkt neben dem beruf ich
wollte dich vorsicht vergessen haben und
richtig vergessen schnell ja noch sechs
minuten
aber ich wusste noch zurückkommen wird
von den kommunen schlagen ja ihre geht
jetzt schnell so nennt sich ein haus
kann man ja das war nicht überspringen
habe okay wir können uns da oben rein
was ist das nein du musst durch die tür
gehen nicht gerade auf mein haus das ist
mein haus einer kaputten kirche
die tür benutzen ohne kreuz das ist die
vergewaltigungs kirche wurdest du hier
geboren wo hätte ich meinen bumerang
kommt mein haus ist das einzel liebe
dich alte nutzen
was ist oder du machst du nichts oder du
warst ein foto von mir ich auf meinem
haus verstehst du hast du auf einem
monitor
das hat man da noch hoch oder ist das
schon denn am 13
wirklich ich hab das direkt neben der
stadt nicht besiegt das glaube ich nicht
okay da sind hier die monster drin aber
wir sollten mehr wahrscheinlich nahm
angst verliefen dann doch jetzt noch
eine treppe
ich bin das ist die witzigste folge
bisher den ganzen projekt also wenn
jetzt aus der thermischen darum hofft
wo ist das lied witzig das ist nur
traurig mehr auf allen möglichen wegen
genehmigung genau das kraftrad kritik
hier wirklich richtig witzig erst das in
unserer stadt also gemacht haben als in
meiner stadt was sie da alles so gemacht
haben und dann findest du mich an und
ich sterbe fast und dann kommen wir hin
und sightseeing tour und so fallen
tristan ja und dann gestürzt dich du
stehst ich hab das errechnet mit einer
formel du hast es errechnet du kriegst
immer du ich schwöre wenn ich dich jetzt
angucke du hast 12 leben und er hat ich
kann gar nicht an punkte auf 15 8 uhr
ist ja schon wird nicht mal genug tanken
doch nur weil es scheiße was nicht
fertig benotet cook und jetzt bin ich
hier du kannst mich sogar unter stopfen
gleich im moment wenn du fertig bist du
hast ein video und ich möchte die stadt
traum ich freue mich dahin zu ihm hin
zustände das nicht unterstützen weil ich
habe keine fehde das weißt du
ich kann entweder ich habe einen nur
eine ich kann mir gleich aber meine
geben ich wollte zwar eigentlich mit
vier federn mit vier goldenen feder kann
man sich allerdings machen ja das
wirklich machen schuhe aber wenn man was
ist der vorteil von ihnen schon ja weiß
ich nicht mal kannst du ganz
überspringen
stina den ich bin nett ich gebe jetzt
meine kloppo viele wissen benutzt
dankeschön aber du kriegst kein falsch
haben wenn mich jetzt unterstützen nicht
nur eine etage
guck mal auch das will ich das foto
machen und klebestellen es hier so
runter muss hochlauf las habe ich nicht
mehr
jaja aber andere schlimm mit hinein fort
ok foto bereit
festlich menschen denn schon schön bist
du auch schöner willst du lieber so
hässlich sein
du willst du weißt ich sein nein nein
ich mache ja so verschieden ich
verschiebt es die so das mikro dann
mache ich so in die max mews an und so
weiter ich hab snap dennoch an
du hast doch gar nicht auf ein snapshot
geantwortet ist wahrscheinlich ein
update unterlegt blöder pizza du du hast
noch nie zu ich hab jetzt kann muss man
darauf ich gehe jetzt nicht so leicht
was wieder pro inception nein das
schaffe ich jetzt nicht ich will den
fall wie jetzt außerdem klar was
passiert wenn ich nicht außerdem schlage
richter kam gemacht
ich voll und schaffe aber hallo denen
sich bitte an ich habe diese verfügung
die zu töten
weiter du hast eine feder jolo
wer weiß das schon so gedacht oh [ __ ]
vielleicht liegt das doch nicht dachte
wir wollen lernen aufgelaufen besser ist
eine starke mannschaft da bin ich echt
aufgeschmissen
aber ich habe eben meine ja soll ich mal
eben immer ein häuslein ein dann
ertrinkt neben einem café und damit er
schnell nach hause
dann bringe ich noch nach hause sondern
gehabt und dann und dann ja shit ich es
nicht so was hast du getan
ich hab' ich gedreht ich habe einen
moonwalk rausgehauen
ich muss schnell aus trinken also nur
dann es pressiert jaja ich weiss die
einen oder zwei
hier muss noch wie martin ich hab mich
auch so mitten in redwood hier kommt
noch ein kleine treppe hingabe an das
was ich bin jetzt im hause aber können
jeden fall auch hier wäre auch ein
bisschen halloween deko ich ihn gemacht
soll ich jetzt nicht mehr dabei re wie
kaffee wurde der noch radfahren tag und
nacht
diese schlechte medley musik da vor ort
mit reisen so ja du musst das tor wieder
zu machen
ich mach das doch okay es hat mich sehr
gefreut es hat mich sehr gefreut mit dir
zusammen
in dieser folge deiner stadt zu besuchen
ja und du warst auch manche haben angst
dass er einst angst einflößte wenn
unsere kunst aber manchmal fand ich auch
ganz nett
paco coach marco w ich habe ich hab
nicht mehr volles leben gab dort 20
ich habe drei herzen gehabt das war das
schön ja gut freude will ich sagen wobei
im showbiz überzogen ich glaub jetzt
noch ganz kurz zu mir nach hause und
dann sehe ich eben eine zu schöne
abschluss einfach noch ein bisschen menü
und gar nicht herauskommen wieder gab
sich nach oben irgendwo habe ich auch
gemacht ja ich muss das loch zu
schließen was weil ich finde es nicht
schön wenn man so ein loch war drin hat
habe ich einmal aufgemacht jetzt
abgeschlossen aber das ist es fünf
minuten später aufgefallen bin ja gut
leute etwa rinder schöne folge mit denen
wir können jetzt übrigens immer zwischen
stadt und statt
das bin ich glaube ich weiß nicht mehr
welches habe du hast ja ich bin bloß
zwölften würde ja wir können es immer
ein bisschen porten das eigentlich ganz
schön
ich kenne das dach ganze ist eigentlich
und ich fand die folgerichtig war die
folge richtig was gemacht also wie
gesagt wenn es euch auch gefallen hat
dann verdientermaßen das ist doch für
mich bisher die beste frau hero gewesen
na ja das habe ich bisher noch nicht
gesagt aber auch im heutigen donnerstag
also bis heute auszeichnen
naja hab ich ja gesagt also heute stehen
auf die uhr gucken doch ist noch den
astag 1 stunde noch das nicht ganz
zufrieden war mit theorie bisher so
fallen somit mein folgen so aber heute
war ich hier eine geile folge und da
also lokal haben wir schritt gemacht
richtig gute sachen richtig tolle sachen
gemacht weil sie das irgendwo angebaut
aber wir haben nicht mitgemacht er war
einfach scheiße gemacht
ich habe auch ein bisschen gebaut siehst
du nicht arbeitet gewissen gebaut und
schon hat eine goldene feder und einen
der zwei diamanten und die austria
kriegen bekommen der die pinkes holz
beschwert das ist also so was tolles
habe ich ja noch nie gehört deswegen das
war echt geil folge gewannen dadurch den
daumen nach oben anschaut dabei locker
vorbei jetzt auch hoch aus seiner
perspektive und damit auch hier weiß
auch in den beschreibungen drin
vielen dank bis zu 130 68